هذا الصندوق لا يحسم فقط من سيسيطر على
الكونغرس الامريكي بعد الانتخابات النصفيه
فقط بل قد يكون اول خطوه في طريق تراجع
الحزبين الاقدم في البلاد
الديمقراطي والجمهوريه عده دلائل تشير الى
فكره السياسه التقليديه في امريكا التي
يهيمن عليها الجمهوريون والديمقراطيون
بالكامل تقريبا
في الانهيار
حتى وان كنا لا نسمع في اي مناسبه سياسيه
امريكيه سوى اثنين الجمهوري والديمقراطي
الا ان هناك جبهه اخرى تحارب السياسيه وهم
المستقلون فئه تعاض مع عدد الناخبينها
خلال العقدين
فحسب استطلاعين اجرتهم مؤسسه جالوب في
سبتمبر حول الانتماء الحزبي روح اذا تقدم
للناخبين الذين يعتبرون انفسهم مستقلين
بنسبه 43% مقارنه بعام 2004 بنحو 27% فقط
ومع السياء الناخبين من الحسبين
الديمقراطي والجمهوري برزات توقعات بزياده
نسبه الناخبين في ما يقرب من ثلاثه ارباع
الولايات عام 2035 ايضا بدات حظوظ
المرشحين المستقلين في التحسن
اهو انتمانيشن
قد لا تبدو رغبه المستقلين بالخروج من
عباءه حزب معين مستعجنه بالنظر الى كون
صراع الحمار الديمقراطي مع الفيل الجمهوري
يعود لقرابه مئه و 168 سنه ولا يزال
مستمرا حتى يومنا هذا بدا الصراع عام
1854 مع الرئيس الديمقراطي الرابعه عشر
للولايات المتحده
رئيس السادس عشر الجمهوري ابراهام لينكولن
الذي انتزع المنصبه من الديمقراطيين وبدات
معها مرحله التنافسي بين الحزبين
وبعيدا عن حاله الصراع الداخليه بين
الديمقراطيين والجمهوريين يقف الناخب
الامريكي متخوفا من مصير ذلك التشذي على
مستقبل بلادهم حيث اظهر استطلاع راي اجرته
شبكته ام بي سي نيوز ان حوالي 80 بالمئه
من الديمقراطيين والجمهوريين يعتقدون ان
المعارضه السياسيه تشكل تهدينا وان عدم
وضع حد لها قد يدمر امريكا التي يعرفونها
بينما يؤكد ثلث الناخبين الديمقراطيين
والجمهوريين انهم ما زالوا يدعمون المرشح
السياسيه لحزبهم حتى ان كان ذلك المرشح لا
يتوافقوا مع توجهاتهم